[Music]
morgan is with us in jacksonville
florida hi morgan welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi dave and rachel um so i just had a
christian
um me and my husband we bought a house
eight months ago out in the country it's
like a it's a really beautiful house
it's on a
on a small river on a small river third
acre or a third yeah third of an acre
but
um we thought it was a manufactured home
and it's actually a modular home
um but you really can't tell because it
has like a big porch and like
a detached garage and things and so
we've been like putting a lot into it
because we like kind of want to
be like our family home and um but we
recently have just discovered that it
has like a
two very very large problems and one of
them
one of them it's not technically a
problem yet but it will be a problem
um in the next few years and so we were
we were trying to see if we would we
should stay in this house or if it would
be
wise to like stay in this house for as
long as we wanted we were hope we were
wanting to like stay for like seven to
nine years until we like outgrow the
house
but um we were just wondering if like i
don't know if we could get the money
back
if we did fix the larger issue and so i
was just
wondering if you guys would advise that
we should
leave the house what are the two things
what are the two things what do they
cost and what'd you pay for the house
um so we paid 156 for the house um
and one of the problems we recently
discovered that there was water damage
in the mudroom
and so we that's like the urgent
problem that we currently are having to
go back in
our baby steps into our emergency fund
to fix because there's like mold and
rotting wood on in the floor and um but
what's that going to cost what's that
going to cost i'm hoping under 10
000. okay so what's the other problem
um it's a foundation problem we've
recently had a lot of cracking in the
house
there was already a lot of cracking but
the cracks have gotten wider just in the
eight months that we've been here
and so um the guy that we had come out
today
he said that with doing it at the very
cheapest it was probably going to be 15
000
but he couldn't even do it and so the
people that could do it are
much more expensive um
company so they were they would probably
be more around twenty thousand
six he said he said that he did
he did say that yeah okay so you don't
have enough information yet
your feelings are hurt that your new
house is broken
okay yeah you don't have a financial
catastrophe
okay fix the mud room get five bids
and spend six months studying the
foundation before you make a decision on
it
foundation repair is full of
the people that do it are uh there are
groups of people that do it that are
wonderful people
and there's a bunch of jack legs that
just make up crap as they're going
and i think that's who you met today
well he was
he yeah i know he was nice but you he
also didn't know how to fix it he also
gave you an estimate about what another
person's company would charge you
which is making up crap yeah you pulled
that out of his ear
he had a small the other company we
called the other company
and we called the manufacturer of the
house and they were saying that we would
only because it has like this mental
uh like this protection underneath this
insulated protection in the crawl space
he said that we would um like he said
we'd have to get a specific
kind of foundation specialist which
there's a it's like a really small town
we live in
and so the closest one um you have had
you've had three conversations and
you're ready to move okay
don't do it no fix the mud room
and spend six months studying the
foundation
getting more bids talking to more people
finding more ways to fix it
there's a lot of things you can do to
foundations
there's more than just one possible fix
and there's certainly more
than just one possible company even if
you're
quote unquote out in the country you can
pay people five thousand dollars and
they will come
out in the country and fix this for
seven
i don't know i'm making this up but you
don't know this yet and so you've got to
gather
more information when's the point that
you would say
no yeah you need to move that it's not
worth fixing because in order to
sell it you got to fix it you have to
disclose yeah you have to fix it you
have to disclose it right
one of the two i mean if it was an 80
000 repair on this
i'd have a lawsuit against the seller
for not disclosing
you know at that point the people that
sold it to them and the real estate
agents are involved and the
home inspector that missed the
inspection which by the way never buy a
home
without an inspection and these are the
reasons right here
so you don't get your heart broken on
the thing that you thought you were
going to be in love with for nine years
and now you find out you got mud room
with mold and a crack foundation
so foundations in different states
and in different regions are sitting on
different kinds of soil
and there's all kinds of different
situations
um with you being in florida you're
probably sitting on some version of sand
and um
so you know it's probably some version
of slab and i don't know you gotta
you're just gonna have to look at it
and get in there and figure out what
they do in tennessee the fix would be
different than it is in florida
but i have owned over 2000 pieces of
real estate i did rehabs for a living
for a decade and one thing i know is
is that it's guys working on houses are
kind of like doctors
they are practicing that's why they call
it a medical practice
they're making crap up as they go and
they proved that during covid
uh they didn't know what they were doing
and so they just did stuff
and so they're practicing medicine
and some of them are better at
practicing than others
and um none of them apparently are good
at math
but the same thing's true of
foundational people they're practicing
they're trying to figure it out and
they're looking at three little cracks
and trying to figure out how to fix your
house you need more information before
you shut the economy down
that's what you're going to do this is
the dave ramsey show